I'm curious what your take is on artists
creativity and sort of altered states of
consciousness be it via drug use I know
philip k dick he dabbled in
methamphetamines going to call the
mother's little helpers or whatever they
were before speed was sort of taken off
the market like that what is your
thoughts on artists either drinking or
using drugs to sort of access that other
part of their mind and create these
other worlds you know it's a great topic
it's a great subject I mean people have
written books on it and I guess I don't
think drugs can make anyone a great
artist I think drugs have probably
destroyed more great artists drugs and
drink than they've enhanced but
certainly a lot of people have have have
been able to survive these experiences
and come back with an interesting
aesthetic point of view I mean you know
from the Beatles and Bob Dylan to to the
Grateful Dead to Ken Kesey going back to
Baudelaire in France and and Rambo who i
think it was sort of the grandfather of
it all Rambo wrote about the scientific
derangement of the senses I think philip
k dick was a writer who didn't want to
be seen as a druggie writer but he did
write a lot about drugs and he dabbled
in them I think he you know I know that
he used pot and I think that he used he
must have used to loosen degenics at one
time or another I don't think he wrote
under the influence of them I think if
you ask most artists what they think
about creating under the influence of
drugs they'll tell you you think you're
brilliant and that it's a
and then you read it or watch it or look
at the next morning and it's it's
incomprehensible and you feel like an
idiot you know I've kind of taken to not
drinking when I go to parties and now I
realize you know when I watch other
people who are drinking at parties just
how witty they all think they are and I
realize I was among those people who
thought oh how clever I am and no you're
not you're not that clever when you
drink Jon you're not clever at all and
I'm much happier kind of trying to to
not laugh at people when they get drunk
a little bit and staying staying sober
i'm not i'm not a teetotaler but i just
think it's more fun not to not to drink
at parties and you know drugs drugs
district just destroy people's lives and
if you're lucky enough to have been able
to use them a little bit and get a
little bit of perspective it helps you
artistically that's that's great but
it's a risky bargain I guess is what I
would say yeah I I think up for me like
we were talking about Tennessee Williams
earlier you know clearly drink he drank
because there was some pain or something
that he had to dal or get out so it
helped him get through the day I'm not
sure it made him a better writer and
that's sort of i think that all drugs
alcohol it's something that we do to
help deaden the pain or to help us get
through the day that I think sometimes
writing or being creative can help us
get through that that hard
thing inside of us that we're facing but
to me it drug drugs drugs just scare me
you know because they've seen them
obliterate and wipe out so many people
not just the creativity but they're like
so yeah it's a fascinating subject and
when I actually want to explore in a
film at some point I knew Timothy Leary
and richard albert I knew Richard Alpert
fairly well I knew Timothy Leary a
little bit and it's a fascinating topic